hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have what the
fuck am i doing
no really what the fuck am i doing
I'll tell you what I'm doing scooby-doo
the douche horse movie here's what I
think of the movie
if fuckin sucks the act no no I wouldn't
do that to you but at the same time it's
this it is this really life no this is a
life this isn't anything even
representing life but its life for me
it's pretty pathetic but it's all I got
I know what you're saying well that's
pretty sad oh yeah this fucking sad I
don't get to go out and hang with
friends I don't even have any friends I
have nobody to contribute anything to I
have nobody to talk to a bounce things
off of you know say hey what'd you think
of it I'll tell you I think I think oh
it's just me bitching and moaning like I
always do and some would say learn to
preset existence oh yeah there's a
pleasing to suggests a I mean for god
sakes I never I never done anything to
make someone's life better or harder
gone in to play a game with somebody
ever play again with somebody wouldn't
be great I mean somebody's just like the
Boy Wonder you ever play this game with
us what game
Parcheesi I don't know the fuck people
are playing but you know what it'd be
nice gonna be nice to be invited I've
never even gone out to a bar with
somebody hey listen friends I've never
gone to a strip club okay I've gone to a
couple strip clubs but I've never gone
with anybody I've never been there and
actually been like again not with people
but spell you know what it'd be nice
it'd be nice just one day to go
somewhere where somebody's just having a
good time and somebody just says out of
nowhere hey you know what that guy was
okay not great but she was okay instead
of hey cool is that little fuck shit
I'll tell you what shit is hey Tyler
dojo credit hey remember tensou yeah ah
but they have to even though every
fucking day exist
he wishes he didn't have to he wishes he
didn't do this bullshit to make you what
and get you ratings and why does it
happen why do you keep coming back
because he are fucking second I'm
fucking stupid that's the way it is
that's all we're towing gotta be there's
no change there's no future there's no
gas the present is a joke everything is
how my life is hell this is the worst
thing
I'll give it be whatever so let's start
uh this is where I usually show up you
clips from the trailer because I was too
lazy to find any actual clips that are
visually interesting for you
and I of course talked over it I mean
what's the point in trying to change
anything right I am where I am nothing's
going to making a difference it's not
like I can just go back in time and
alert my young self of the hell that
awaits him alright Scooby Doo the movie
this is gonna be so clever and that ah
what the hell holy shit it's like
looking into the future is that me from
the past
oh hey does the internet ever become
anything or do we still just use it for
porn its Horan isn't it wait a minute
this doesn't make any sense
how am i able to talk to my younger self
no no maybe has something to do with the
fact I'm about to watch the awesome
scooby-doo movie it's great because I
remember scooby-doo existed and this
movie remembers that scooby-doo existed
so it's really tapping into my childhood
what's the word I'm looking for
it's Dasia now that's not it what look
younger me whatever you do don't watch
that piece of crap what but they say
it's a satirical hip new look at the
characters I know and love but it's not
done well it's just a corporate sellout
a woman forget it I hate corporate
sellouts they're all north they can all
just kiss my ass hey by the way what's
it like making put zillions of dollars
selling your ideas uh yeah about that
a little word of advice from your future
self uh you may not want to keep making
those videos what why not trust me
they're not as good as you think they
are well what the hell do you know you
stupid close-minded narc I knew you
dumbass yeah well how do I know the
corporation's didn't get to you how do I
know they didn't find you in like
brainwash into talking to your younger
self convincing me not to make it a
greatest movies of all time
look I'm not making this up listen to me
this is totally believable you need to
stop because mara Wilson the little girl
from mrs. Doubtfire is going to find
them and blackmail you with them years
later dude that seriously the best you
could come up with my if all you could
see the future so you can understand
what's in store free possum are you
doing here alright what's going on here
I don't know it's like all these
different parts in my life are coming
together the past president future all I
want to do was just watch the fucking
scooby-doo movie please I was going to
put it on - I met Maria scooby-doo is so
bad I was going to put it on to see if I
can't remember it
huh but wait both I and the young me
we're gonna watch it - great we're all
gonna watch the same movie yeah so I
guess somehow it caused a temporal
anomaly in time hmm we best watch this
movie together Critic something tells me
that all the answers to our questions
may be in this peril Oh trust me this
film ants no answers speak for yourself
narc oh shut up you pretentious little I
don't make me split myself apart
he started it narc well let's go ahead
see we can figure out what's going on
let's watch the scooby-doo movie so the
film opens with big shock a pop song
yeah but so what the original hip-hop
songs - yeah and I'm sure that never
dated either just like having sandy
Duncan or the Harlem Globetrotters who
exactly so after listening to
I don't know Scoob doggy dog we start
off with a caper going on or rather the
end of the caper actually shockingly
that means been captured again when the
Luna ghost rounds the corner with Daphne
Shaggy and Scooby would pop out of the
barrel then you'll activate the conveyor
belt spilling the battle oil on the
floor ah did we fast forward past a few
scenes yeah it's weird isn't it
they're giving you a taste of what one
of the capers on the show was like but
you wouldn't really get that unless you
grew up watching the show well I did and
I think it's very clever dr. satirizing
the original showing that they have a
sense of humor by making Scooby look
like Marmaduke seriously is that
supposed to be scooby-doo it barely
looks like him it looks more like a
gremlin that got microwaved with a bear
rug not to mention the crappy CGI
effects tell me did they really look
that bad in your time period well not
this bad but hey maybe it's a loving
send up to the bad animation of the
original show yeah but the original show
had an excuse for why it was bad
each episode had the budget of a ham
sandwich of two minutes to put it
together what's this films excuse well
it is kind of neat though how they're
making fun of their roles like how
Daphne's the damsel in distress Velma's
the smart one Fred's full of himself
look they're even mocking the pointless
celebrity cameos uh I don't think that's
mocking a pointless celebrity cameo I
think that just is a pointless celebrity
cameo this is a victory for any
celebrity who wants to make a quality
ecologically friendly actually figure
Hey look Michael Moore and the Jerry
Maguire kid come on it's a satire of the
original show and that automatically
makes it funny show me something that's
a sad tire that isn't automatically
funny I don't know what those are yet
Oh Smithers the creepy janitor well
maybe if they keep it going throughout
the rest of the film but I don't know it
seems like they're playing their cards
pretty early if the whole film is
supposed to satirize the show
why aren't they saving these jokes for
the rest of the movie why are they using
them up in the first couple minutes
it's spoiling the fun early for fans and
confusing newcomers it's like the Brady
Bunch movie they'll have a ton of jokes
like this throughout the entire I quit
minute I was gonna quit in like two
seconds yeah I quit well that seemed
like a relatively short flick good
riddance well they never did that in the
show
yeah even from a dramatic standpoint
that seems a little early to throw it
wouldn't it make more sense that they
save this for like the end of the second
act or something well hey maybe they get
right back together real Saluki talk
about dosage on purpose
so yeah a mere two years passes by as
suddenly the owner of an amusement park
called spooky island context and one by
one and fools them all out into coming
out to solve the mystery they decided to
all go but not after establishing that
each one of them wants to solve the
mystery themselves I was gonna solve the
mystery of myself for the first time
ever are you gonna save yourself and you
get caught I'm a black belt now I've
transformed my body into a dangerous
weapon look okay I'm a little confused I
thought in the show they all liked each
other did what how come they don't like
each other no because I clever no here's
fucking clever
no no no I'm sorry I just got back from
the movie theater from seeing the must
also will give all time the two towers
and that had fucking Gaul a minute that
is one of the best CG characters of all
time
and yet this abomination came out the
exact same year are you shitting me for
god sakes Roger Rabbit was better
integrated than him and I'm supposed to
know that he's not really there
that is a beautiful work heart uh-huh oh
here's a fun little fact for you Elsa
Fisher's in this movie estimate fish
your own best sweet honey from wedding
crashers
whoo oh you don't know where yet but
she's one of the most attractive women
you'll ever see in your life oh my god
she is such a hobbit you mind me taking
a seat there who the hell is that
that s la Fisher really her um she's
okay I guess no mono they make her like
mother pretties women of all time she's
like a knockout
if you say so no and she's funny too
really really funny but he's everything
me
I swear to gosh if he goes really really
funny really no really she's funny and
attractive but this is really great
scene where she ties fits onto a bed it
puts us what exact in his bulk do I have
to become you it works in context so
take a guess with the young lady who
befriends Scooby and Shaggy is named No
really yes the first thing that pops
into your mind is probably correct I'm
Mary Jane Mary Jane her name is actually
Mary Jane like that is my favorite name
yeah oh dude you should totally meet her
sister pot oh and here's another weird
one she just loves Scooby Snacks yeah
what are the odds they're 100%
vegetarian and and I love them like me
too I have never met another person who
loves boobies max me neither it's like
finding the really hot chick who loves
playing video games eating hot pockets
and living in your mother's house or the
one who likes Vince Vaughn tied to a bed
with a
Aachen is that words in context cause
the dog to discontinue any action simply
flick it on the nose hey did that dog
just punch someone oh yeah
Scooby performed physical assault yeah
Alan is a part of my childhood feel
ravaged oh fuck you asshole oh so they
get to the island and find out that it
was mr. Dean who called them there why
because not only does he have a mystery
for them to solve but he wanted to see
them all back together to relive that
nostalgic feel there's that word again
I don't think you know the proper
meaning uh I believe somebody is casting
a spell students have you notice any
difference between those arriving and
those departing they look like sober
well-behaved college kids precisely if
they didn't before they came in other
words a magic spell now wait a minute
magic spells come on the original
scooby-doo made it very clear that
there's no such thing as supernatural
elements in their world just a talking
dog who has an appetite for six foot
sandwiches oh thanks for being the voice
of reason no problem so they try to
figure out what's been causing all the
teenagers on the island to act so
strange by looking into one of the
closed attractions
Daphney exit through the entrance Velma
and I will enter here through the exit
there and Shaggy and Scooby do whatever
you guys do I didn't think it was
possible but this Fred actually has less
of a personality than the original
friend fact they probably just picked an
actor who could already answer to his
name
hello normally it's the actors chewing
the scenery not the scenery chewing the
app yes yeah that's a good point
even the sets have a little too much
going on it's hard to make much of it
out to appreciate the design and the
actors often get lost in it but it's
okay it won't just drive from the
pointman slapstick we have here
why is this funny in a cartoon and not
really here because a cartoon goes out
of its way to convince you that it's
alive this film goes out of its way to
convince you there's no life in it
whatsoever
Wow I guess that does make sense huh
critic panic crush here honest what's
going on here
where am I you're my realm now predict a
world with no past present or future
poor you know old friend
you
Roger did that jr. I figured out that Oh
guardian angel from immortal they are
swing just go into they da Wow
so how many angels are here just me
apparently I was the only one that
didn't figure out angels could get
murdered thermal anomalies not dead then
on that kind of dude what good you know
in this round I I don't believe you oh
and do you have a purgatory where you
just go no well you saw like an extra
knot it yeah tell you what why don't I
just leave and you just can't enjoy hey
guys critics in charge now yes yes the
credit is in charge of purgatory that's
right just like a freakin college job
who thinks he knows everything cuz you
watch on MSNBC I comprehend everything
about politics but he's never really
done it this guy's done okay so how I
snapped I'll tell you what I'll only
answer yes or no questions first time
you've asked one that isn't yes no
question you can ask anymore why is that
oh my god you're just wasted you just
wasted you may give it one chance and
you've wasted let's go second what do
you want war on this one be yes or no
questions I wasn't full deck you know
what strip you're on your own oh come on
give me a hand if all mankind is doing
it at least give me a hand
all I can tell you is it as something to
do with your review that you
why think of this my way of saying
thanks but guys the end of the world is
upon us if we don't do something all
mankind is doomed
oh what's the way to I don't know where
do we go I don't know I was her anything
you don't know yes it has something to
do with this review so we should just
keep watching the review yes okay glad
you brought that up who knows what we
might have been doing if you didn't
mention that so no man Fred come across
a video that sort of shows the villains
evil plan interaction between young
people is polite and casual hey sorry
bro I will crush my bones into dust
let's see how the situation should be
handled sorry bro
no big whoop Dawg yo would you catch
that new vid on the box true dat I'm up
two stairs off on all popular trends
word white people making life uncool
since the dawn of time so they figure
mr. bean is the culprit but there's
still an hour left of the movie so it
seems kind of unlikely but rather than
gather more clues we have this lovely
scene that we're forced to sit through
you know just for fun why don't we see
how much every single gas joke would
cost an animator to animate it also how
much could have gone to a charity to
stop people from watching this film oh
the good cause this money could have
gone too hey your friends did you know I
always get the brain worm Hey look well
let's talk into a guy for a minute I
guess that means I gotta get together at
the end oh please everybody knows that
she's saving herself for Daphne really
focusing on a mystery reminds me in the
old days we were quite a crew back then
but every family has one not happy to
repeat that we do Oh God
scrappy-doo is in this movie I can't
remember who is he again just one of the
most annoying shit piles under squirted
Kevin when I find him I'll give him a
good dose up puppy power
shut up oh god he's peeing on me and as
we all know there's nothing funnier in
the early 2000s than a dog at urinates
on cue rappy I told you no urinating on
dad that's my job to be fair though they
do make him intentionally annoying in
fact he's actually cast out in just a
few seconds honestly it doesn't make any
sense
I need scooby is supposed to be his
caretaker I remember that so casting the
kid to the side of the road in the
middle of nowhere just leaving him to
die that's a pretty big asshole thing to
do isn't it I mean that's downright evil
for such an innocent character what a
bitch or a male bitch
a little egomaniac had flipped his lid
you don't have a stroke for this job
Hobby hell if that's the case why is
that scene even in the movie it's only a
couple seconds long it's just an
annoying bit of nothing what's the
purpose of it maybe he's the villain
what what oh the scenes only a couple
Ekans long and they're not writing a
good mystery and it's entirely pointless
maybe that's the only point to having it
just to make him a bad guy no no it'd
just be too stupid it makes so little
sense right I think maybe we should keep
watching the review yeah let's keep
going
oh I remember those supernatural
elements we said just a moment ago were
never in the original show well throw
over in this one and sadly it looks like
they can only afford one design for
these creatures which I guess is
understandable all the money obviously
had to go to the Scoobies there I did my
one line for the trailer now let's get
out of here and doesn't meet or does it
look like those supernatural beings
smoked a few too many Marlboro
cigarettes trust me it's not wise for
supernatural beings to be smoking
Marlboro cigarettes I convinced an alien
race to take up smoking once and well
let's just say it didn't turn out well
so friggin Velma get captured it's up to
Daphne Scooby Doo Shaggy and Mary Jane
to go save them so we can defeat the
creatures and save Fred and Velma well
that's sort of like my plan we'll just
get the heck out of here let the
creatures eat friend Bobo okay I never
thought I'd say this but that was too
cowardly honestly shaggy would run away
but not at the cost of sacrificing his
friends it's okay to make fun of the
characters but not when it's out of
character shaggy will never be that
cruel Fred and Velma always figured out
everything my middle name is Judas but
they discovered that again through the
supernatural powers they've turned Fred
into more of a tool than usual man we
got beats like it was the liz's on earth
no i'm Sanji well now he's just acting
like Freddie Prinze jr. Fred turns his
teen friends against our heroes and
tracks them down get the dog hey
thinking ollie
you know
they escape and find a way into the
center of a villains lair
thank God I'm so high I can't feel my a
broken bones shaggy Tim finds the souls
of all the people who had their souls
sucked out okay this is really stupid
and he tries to return them to the
proper bodies that's one part of the
mystery solved the creatures must need
our bodies to survive in sunlight like a
human suit SPF one million whatever
keeps you talking in that top I am
totally fine with but some of the bodies
get a little mixed up I couldn't get to
my body I didn't know where else to go I
grant it I can look at myself naked
ah this movie was intended for children
right I don't think it was meant for
anybody once they get their bodies back
in sync they sneak into the bad guys
evil tomb where Mr Bean who apparently
is Captain Crunch Chocula is about to
perform an evil ceremony to steal all
the islands souls but the team knocks
him out and find out who he really is
Oh oh man
robot actually no believe it or not it's
scrappy puppy power
Oh colder child for the lady serious
that's right
scrappy was the villain the whole time
how can something sound so right and you
feel so wrong cuz my scrappy-dappy-doo
have absorbed enough energy to rule the
world with my all-powerful in a much
more clever a movie this would actually
be hilarious but here it's just kind of
awkward it feels like last-minute
fanfiction
it's the biggest twist since finding out
Martin was the bad guy in secret of NIMH
- a real jaw dropper yeah
what is he transforming into Pumbaa
hello Timon I've come to eat your soul
we also get the end of Daphne's
incredibly complex story arc now who's
the damsel distress me straight I don't
even get it was Danny really captured
that often oh no I seem to remember
Scooby and Shaggy being a more peril
than her hell I don't even scrappy had
to be saved more times I think it's more
she never did anything as opposed to
getting captured all the time but yeah
it's still a little confused but hey
they do stop the evil scrappy and his
satanic powers of hell oh god how could
they not make this joke work her look
Velma hooks up with that guy she shared
a sentence with call that one too and so
does rather than Daphne that's kind of
confusing yeah were they a thing in the
original show I don't know young me uh
kind of sort of not really people always
like to hint at it like maybe they had a
thing going but they never actually
shared any chemistry on the show oh then
the movie in the shuttle has something
in common yeah we're in the film did
they ever indicate they have a romantic
interest and now you're telling me that
technically it didn't even exist in the
show I mean does any of this satisfy any
audience what's so fucking ever
I mean scooby-doo is the ultimate
nostalgic dream it existed long ago it
exists today it will probably continue
to exist in the future whatever it is
there is just some sort of weird awkward
simple charm to the original that is
apparently trying to carry through but
does it work in this fucking piece of
shit
oh now well I know for whatever reason
scooby-doo continues to keep going
there's tons of reincarnations there's
tons of different versions there's kind
of different takes but most of them keep
what is essentially the scooby-doo
formula
character except for fucking this if it
want to be a satire fine if it wanted to
be a homage fine but this is just a
cluttered unfocused mess the effects are
horrible the jokes fall flat and the
characters aren't identifiable unless
you watch the show and even then they're
not that loyal to them they're mostly
just cardboard cutouts are stereotypes
of the original characters and even then
they're not really half the time
stereotypes of the original character
they're just stereotypes of stereotypes
it's incredible not only how much this
movie misses the point and the ideas of
the original show but how many different
moods and angles it's trying to attack
him with and how many events don't work
and worst of all making scrappy do the
villains now from my point of view I
don't remember watching the show at all
so inserting him as The Bacchae makes no
sense as a film on its own yeah and from
my standpoint it made no sense because I
know the characters and the characters
would never do this scrappy-doo will
never be evil scooby-doo whenever
abandoned him on the side of the street
and the series would never be this
mean-spirited yeah and from my point of
view it doesn't make sense because it
wasn't fully developed from a comedic
standpoint why because the movie doesn't
know if it wants to be mean-spirited
light-hearted or both but whatever it's
trying to be it doesn't work it just
straight-up
fails and it's straight of sucks this
movie can cock my ass
much left but temporal anomoly is taking
its toll
well yeah it's gonna wipe us out dan we
could never figure out the answers oh
god how could something so horrible wait
a minute that's it something so horrible
something so horrible we all sat through
the horrible movie what what do you mean
the past present future it never managed
to please anybody think about it it
doesn't mean up to the nostalgic
memories of the past the current
judgments of the present or the fresh
thoughts of the future it fails on all
accounts and it's destroying us all well
when we do that the only thing we can do
we have to destroy it in every time
period
gnarrk
this is it no turning back goodbye
critic Anna laughs but as we all know
all good things must come to it well see
Roger will see hey scooby-doo where are
you
I'll tell you where
gee what happened
did it work are they only in the only
okay the old me the young me next you'll
be worrying about your goldfish come on
you know I hate them a while ago yes you
save humanity
once again yeah awesome bro yeah all the
world
you owe me haha celebrated yeah guess
I've known good to celebrate with maybe
this time you can do things a little
different but Roger there's something I
don't understand
it's something I've never understood
about film if a movie is so bad and
everybody hates it then why is it still
a big hit why do so many people keep
watching well yeah oh I won't but I will
tell you there is much that awaits you
possibly beyond your wildest dreams
come on terrified in your worst
nightmare either way I'll be watching
and always making sure you have
something to critique
see
I was really quite beautiful - hey hey
Rob what are you doing getting snacks
for the poker game
poker game I never knew he did poker
game here told you every night for the
past five years
you just never listened I'm a dinosaur
but
so go to Christmas future you're the
Grim Reaper as well well being the angel
death is my kind of 5 job I did every
goose to Christmas future taking around
the holidays just attack the wallet got
three kids and then I can why forgot my
presents for all of us
it's nightmare Hamid a bizarre this is
indisputably true well I think I'm gonna
win tonight because I've been studying
both your poker faces good luck um is
there a problem
no I just thought I'd join you this
evening of course pull up a chair
Kennedy you oh thank you you know I was
actually quite the car player gosh you
were always welcome
well five-card stud nothing wild and the
stars the limit here we already have
cause
I can look at myself naked